I was getting those laughs that you know
there was one joke that I was thinking
of doing where I bring up 911 and I was
like I don't know how they're going to
take
this and I did it and I got that laugh
you know as a comic right I always like
if I'm talking about something outside
of me in my world what I what I do when
I'm in America is I look around the room
to make sure that the subject I'm
talking about those people are laughing
right like say I'm doing a joke about
race that involves black people I'm not
looking at the white people in the crowd
I'm looking at the black people in the
crowd and if they're laughing in the
right
way you know or if they're not laughing
I know I need to keep working on it or I
had this joke about Armenian people and
not only did they laugh they came up I
was like was that right they were like
that 100% I know exactly what you
talking about right and I got that laugh
in Abu Dhabi and after that it was just
I was just cruising and I had the best
time